ahora vamos a ver otros ejemplos de cómo
se resuelven ecuaciones como puedes
notar estas ecuaciones son un poquito
más complicadas requieren más pasos para
llegar al final a la respuesta pero vas
a ver que son muy fáciles de resolver
ahora algo muy divertido acerca de estas
ecuaciones es que hay muchísimos caminos
que puedes seguir y en todos ellos
llegas a la misma respuesta que es la
respuesta correcta eso claro si haces
puros pasos válidos osea puras
operaciones aritméticas y todo lo que le
hagas al lado izquierdo se lo hagas
también al lado derecho entonces pues
empecemos a resolver estas ecuaciones
empecemos por resolver 1.3 x men
0.7 x igual a 12
que bueno al menos el primer instinto
que me sale a mí es tratar de juntar
estos dos términos o sea porque tenemos
aquí 1.3 de esta cosa menos 0.7 de la
misma costa exactamente digo sí que se
pueden llamar manzanas o peras tenemos
aquí 1.3 manzanas menos puntos siete
manzanas entonces por qué no agarramos
si juntamos estos dos términos si
quieres puedes pensar que estamos
haciendo el inverso de la propiedad
distributiva de los números y el chiste
es que nos queda aquí 1.3 menos 0.7 por
esta cosa de nuestras manzanas ok
todo esto de aquí es exactamente igual a
esto de aquí y eso pues en esta ecuación
tenemos que es igual a 12 ok pero 1.3
menos 0.7 eso es 0.6 por nuestras
manzanas nuestra x eso es igual a 12 ok
esta ecuación de acá es equivalente a
esta ecuación de acá pero esta ecuación
es muy parecida a las que estábamos
viendo en el vídeo pasado o sea tenemos
aquí nuestra incógnita nuestra variable
x multiplicada por un coeficiente y eso
es igual a otro número entonces nosotros
sabemos que podemos simplemente dividir
entre 0.6 para que éste se cancele con
este pero todo lo que hagamos del lado
izquierdo del igual también lo tenemos
que hacer del lado derecho del igual o
sea que aquí tenemos que dividir entre 0
punto 6 muy bien entonces ya lo único
que tenemos que hacer es resolver esta
división y ya tenemos a que tiene que
ser igual esta x a ver para resolver
esto tenemos que poner aquí 12
en 3.6 entonces movemos el punto decimal
para acá
así es que tenemos que mover el punto
decimal un lugar para que así es que le
agregamos un 0 por aquí está nuestro
puntito y ahora sí
cuántas veces cabe el 6 dentro de 120
eso vale exactamente lo mismo que
cuántas veces vale el punto 6 dentro del
12 cierto bueno entonces 6 por 2 nos da
12 restamos nos queda 0 bajamos el otro
0 y 6 porque nos da 0 6 por 0 nos da 0 6
por 0 6 por ser unos de acero restamos y
tenemos residuos cero entonces el 6 cabe
20 veces dentro del 120
y lo que es lo mismo el punto 6 cabe 20
veces dentro del 12 entonces 12 entre
0.6 es igual a 20 así es que x es igual
a 20
ok
a ver vamos a verificar nuestra
respuesta y para verificarlo a lo que
tenemos que hacer es sustituir la equis
en cada uno de los lugares de la
ecuación en los que aparezca la equis o
sea aquí y acá entonces nosotros tenemos
1.3 por equis que en este caso es 20
menos 0.7 por 20 en lugar de la equis y
eso queremos verificar si eso es igual a
entonces 1.3 por 20 sabes que vamos a
sacar la calculadora para que no me veas
haciendo tantas cuentas entonces tenemos
que 1.3
por 20 esto es igual a 26 26 esto de
aquí es 26 y luego le tenemos que restar
0.7 por 20
0.7 por 20 eso es 14 entonces esto de
aquí vale 14 y claro que podemos hacer
todas estas cuentas a mano pero me
tardaría más y ya hicimos muchas cuentas
a mano en este vídeo y en el pasado
entonces 1.3 por 20 es 26 y a eso lo
tenemos que restar 0.7 por 20 que es 14
y 26 - 14 eso es igual a 12 así es que
si en efecto x igual a 20 si satisface
esta ecuación ok porque cuando
sustituimos la x por el 20 si tenemos
que este lado de la ecuación es igual a
este lado de la ecuación ok entonces
esta respuesta si es correcta
así es que podemos ir a la siguiente
ecuación ahora vamos a resolver
5 x menos
es x + 2 igual a 15 x menos entre
paréntesis 3 x + 2 eso es igual a 1
tenemos que encontrar x eso se ve mucho
más complicado no bueno cuando te
encuentras con ecuaciones complicadas el
chiste es hacer algunos pasos algunas
operaciones que hagan que la ecuación se
vea más sencilla y no importa cuantos
pasos hagas siempre y cuando cada vez se
vea más simple la ecuación y cada paso
sea un paso que realmente podemos hacer
por ejemplo aquí tenemos menos y un
paréntesis esto lo podemos ver como un
menos uno
por este paréntesis y aquí entonces le
tenemos que poner una y entonces lo que
podemos hacer es distribuir la
multiplicación de este menos uno en este
paréntesis también lo podemos pensar
como que estamos distribuyendo al menos
para que no se vea tan mal vamos a
quitar lo que acabo de poner
y entonces lo que nos queda a la hora de
distribuirlo es 5 x menos 3 x menos 2 y
listo esta expresión es igualita a esta
otra expresión entonces esto tiene que
seguir siendo igual a 1 porque esto es
igual a esto que a su vez es igual a 1
entonces esto es igual a 1 y entonces
ahora tenemos algo que se parece mucho a
la ecuación anterior
aquí tenemos 5 manzanas menos tres
manzanas menos un número igual a otro
número y lo que queremos es llegar a una
expresión de la forma x es igual a otro
número entonces lo que podemos hacer es
juntar estos dos términos tenemos 5
manzanas menos tres manzanas eso es
igual a dos manzanas porque 5 menos 3 es
igual a 2 y tenemos menos 2 igual a 1
y ahora queremos deshacernos de este
menos 2 y la mejor forma que yo conozco
para deshacernos de este menos 2 es
sumando 12 gay porque entonces este 2 se
cancela con este menos 2 y nos queda
simplemente el 2x pero muy importante
muy importante que no se nos va a
olvidar que todo lo que le hagamos al
lado izquierdo se lo tenemos que hacer
al lado derecha entonces aquí nos falta
sumarle 1 2 y 1 + 12 es igual a 3
entonces esta ecuación es la misma
ecuación que 2x igual a 3 muy bien aquí
ya tenemos una ecuación muy parecida a
las del vídeo pasado donde tenemos a
nuestra variable multiplicada por un
coeficiente igual a otro número
así es que podemos resolverlo muy
fácilmente dividiendo entre el
coeficiente que está multiplicando
nuestra variable de los dos lados del
igual ok para que dividido entre 2
puedes dividir entre 2 para que este
coeficiente se cancele con este
coeficiente y nos quede
la equis y entonces nos queda x igual a
medios y listo ahora te va a tocar a ti
verificar que esta respuesta x igual a 3
medios sea una respuesta correcta que y
ahora vamos con la siguiente ecuación
tenemos aquí este menos tres octavos de
ese igual a cinco sextos aunque hay tres
por s entre 8 es lo mismo que tres
octavos de ese entonces aquí tenemos que
encontrar ese y además tenemos una
fracción por este y una s solita sin
ningún coeficiente como le vamos a hacer
bueno pues lo vamos a hacer exactamente
igual que en estas dos ecuaciones ok
vamos a simplificar esta expresión hasta
que se vea muy fácil de resolver
entonces empecemos por pensar en que ese
la podemos ver como un 1 por ese cierto
y entonces podemos factorizar a la s
osea esta cosa de aquí la podemos ver
como una s multiplicando a uno menos
tres octavos
aunque hay entonces tenemos aquí la
vamos a factorizar del lado izquierdo s
por 1 es este término s por 1 menos
por tres octavos la es la dejamos por
acá y ponemos aquí a los tres octavos y
todo esto tiene que ser igual a cinco
sextos y bueno para simplificar este
paréntesis aquí tenemos un 1 menos tres
octavos el 1 lo podemos ver como ocho
octavos porque 8 entre 8 es uno y
entonces aquí tenemos ocho octavos menos
tres octavos eso es cinco octavos que
están multiplicando a ese y eso es igual
a cinco sextos aunque pudimos haberlo
visto desde el principio teníamos por
aquí uno por ese menos tres octavos de
ese esto lo pueden ver como ocho octavos
de ese menos tres octavos de ese
entonces nos quedan simplemente cinco
octavos de ese otra vez hemos llegado a
una ecuación como las del vídeo pasado
tenemos aquí a nuestra variable por un
coeficiente igual a otro número
entonces vamos a multiplicar por el
inverso de este coeficiente osea vamos a
multiplicar por ocho quintos pero todo
lo que hagamos del lado izquierdo lo
tenemos que hacer también del lado
derecho y llega la hora de la cancelada
multiplicamos por ocho quintos para que
este 5 se cancele con este 5 y para que
este 8 se cancele con este 8 que hay
pero por acá este 5 también se cancela
con este 5 y aquí podemos dividir al 6
entre 2 y entonces nos queda 3 y podemos
dividir al 8 entre 2 y nos queda 4
entonces nos queda que s es igual a 4
tercios
entonces aquí tenemos que resolver esta
ecuación donde la variable es q y tu que
dice se ve como una ecuación complicada
aún no bueno con esta ecuación lo que yo
quiero hacer es enseñarte que no importa
qué camino tome mos para resolver esta
ecuación para encontrar qué valor debe
de tener q para que se dé esta igualdad
siempre y cuando realicemos puras
operaciones aritméticas válidas y cada
que sumemos estemos multiplicamos
dividamos de un lado del igual hagamos
lo mismo del otro lado del igual vamos a
llegar exactamente a la misma respuesta
aunque y vamos a reescribir esta
ecuación tenemos aquí
5 12 a vos por q menos 7 igual a dos
tercios y en el primer camino que yo voy
a tomar lo primero que voy a hacer es
multiplicar por el inverso de este
número aunque hay de 5 12 bosh entonces
voy a multiplicar por 12 quintos de los
dos lados del igual
para seguir preservando está igualdad
y para qué hice eso pues lo hice para
que este 12 se cancele con este 12 y
este 5 se cancele con este 5 sin embargo
de este lado del igual también se van a
cancelar algunas cosas podemos aquí
dividir este 12 entre 3 y entonces 2
entre 3 nos queda 4 y este 3 también lo
dividimos entre 3 y nos queda 1 y
entonces aquí nos queda 2 por 48 entre 1
por 55 así es que lo que nos queda es q
menos 7 igual a ocho quintos ahora lo
que queremos es deshacernos de este 7
porque una vez que nos deshagamos de
este 7 nos va a quedar simplemente q
igual a otro número y entonces ya
habremos resuelto esta ecuación ok
esta ya es una ecuación como las del
vídeo pasado no entonces sumamos siete
de los dos lados del igual eso es muy
importante de este lado esto lo podemos
reescribir con ocho quintos más el 7 es
exactamente igual a 35 quintos y de este
lado pues para que sumamos el 7 para que
se cancelara con el menos 7 o sea aquí
tenemos q más 7 menos 7 y eso es igual a
0 que es simplemente una q que resultó
ser igual a 8 35 43
quintos y listo esta es nuestra
respuesta siguiendo este camino
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es resolver
esta ecuación tomando un camino distinto
aunque entonces empecemos por reescribir
nuestra ecuación tenemos por aquí 5 por
q menos 7 entre 12 igual a dos tercios
como que este 12 nos está estorbando por
acá
entonces nos tenemos que deshacer de él
y la mejor forma de deshacernos de un 1
entre 12 es multiplicando por un 12
así es que multiplicamos por 12 de los
dos lados del igual para que este se
cancele con este y bueno de este lado
aquí podemos dividir el 12 entre 3 y de
eso nos va a quedar un 4 entonces aquí 2
entre 3 es un 4 y aquí tenemos 2 por 48
así es que esta ecuación es equivalente
5 por q menos 7 igual a 8 ahora aquí hay
varias cosas que podríamos hacer una de
ellas sería deshacernos de este 5 que
también se ve como que nos está
estorbando no pero eso sería muy
parecido a lo que hicimos en este camino
porque si dividimos entre 5 como
acabamos de multiplicar por 12
eso sería igualito a haber multiplicado
por 12 quintos entonces en realidad
estaríamos siguiendo este camino que ya
hicimos y queremos hacer uno nuevo uno
distinto
así es que pues hay que buscar más
opciones pero aquí tenemos una muy buena
opción aquí en lugar de dividir entre 5
vamos a distribuir esta multiplicación
este paréntesis entonces nos queda 5 por
q más 5 por menos 7
entonces tenemos aquí 5 por q menos 5
por 7 35 igual a 8 ya es una ecuación
mucho más sencilla no o sea esta
ecuación está exactamente la misma
ecuación que esta otra pero esta si se
ve mucho más fácil de resolver no bueno
ese es el chiste eso es lo que tenemos
que hacer simplificar ecuaciones
complicadas quitando las cosas que nos
estorben para que nos queden ecuaciones
fáciles de resolver bueno pero entonces
vamos a resolverla no aquí nos queremos
deshacer de este 35 y la forma más fácil
de hacer eso es sumando 35 de los dos
lados del igual entonces nos queda 835
igual a 43 y por aquí para que sumamos
35 pues para que se cancele con este
menos 35
entonces nos queda 5 porque igual 43 y
esta ya es una ecuación tal cual como
las del vídeo pasado tenemos a la
variable que queremos encontrar por un
coeficiente igual a otro número entonces
podemos simplemente dividir entre el
coeficiente de los dos lados del igual
muy importante y obtenemos la respuesta
q igual a 45 quintos y mira nada más
obtuvimos exactamente la misma respuesta
nos fuimos por dos caminos distintos
pero hicimos todas las operaciones bien
y todo lo que le hacíamos de un lado del
igual también se lo hacíamos del otro
lado del igual y obtuvimos la misma q
bueno me parece que es hora de hacer un
ejercicio con palabras tan es si fue al
centro y gasto casi todo su dinero solo
se quedó con 10 pesos para regresar a su
casa
taxi cuesta punto 75 pesos por kilómetro
pero se agrega un costo inicial de 2.35
pesos
escribe una fórmula y usada para
calcular cuántos kilómetros puede
recorrer en taxi con su dinero y
determinar cuántos kilómetros puede
recorrer entonces se satanice y gastó
casi todo su dinero pero tiene 10 pesos
entonces es atanés si quiere calcular
cuántos kilómetros puede recorrer en
taxi con el dinero que tiene aquí
pongamos una c que represente cuánto
cuesta el taxi y por acá nosotros
tenemos que el taxi cuesta de entrada
cuesta 2 puntos 35 pesos nada más por
subirse al taxi entonces tienen que
pagar 2 puntos 35 pesos
punto 75 pesos por cada kilómetro que
recorran ok está acá representa el
número de kilómetros recorridos acá es
igual a el número de kilómetros
recorridos hueco
2 pero nosotros sabemos que también si
sólo tiene 10 pesos para llegar a su
casa entonces podemos poner aquí en el
lugar del costo del taxi la cantidad de
dinero que tiene tennessee entonces
tenemos aquí los 10 pesos que tiene
tennessee y esos 10 pesos que es lo que
le va a costar atanés y tomar el taxi es
igual a 2.35 más dependiendo de cuántos
kilómetros recorre puntos 75 por esa
cantidad de kilómetros que recorre a ok
ahora queremos ver cuántos kilómetros
puede recorrer también si con estos 10
pesos o sea queremos encontrar cuánto
vale acá para que se satisfaga esta
ecuación entonces lo primero que
queremos hacer es deshacernos de este
2.35 así es que vamos a restar 2.35 de
los dos lados del igual 2
35 porque así este se cancela con este y
de este lado ya nos queda simplemente la
cantidad de kilómetros que puede
recorrer tennessee por punto 75 pero de
este lado vamos a sacar la calculadora
para que no tengas que confiar en que yo
haga las cuentas bien 2.35 negativo más
eso es igual a 7.65 ok 7.65 ok esto es
esto de aquí que es igual a punto 75 por
la cantidad de kilómetros que puede
recorrer tan así entonces para dejar al
acá solita lo único que nos falta es
deshacernos de este punto 75 y la mejor
forma de deshacernos de él es dividiendo
entre punto 75 de los dos lados del
igual
aquí punto 75 se cancela con punto 75 y
nos queda simplemente una acá que es lo
que buscamos y de este lado pues vamos a
sacar la calculadora otra vez no tenemos
aquí 7.65 entre punto 75 y eso es igual
a 10.2 10.2 acá es igual a 10 puntos 2
así es que también se puede recorrer
10.2 kilómetros en taxi con los 10 pesos
que tiene entonces si se encuentra a
menos de 10 puntos 2 kilómetros de su
casa no va a tener ningún problema